Continuing in the book of purification
of al-Wajeez
regarding the
preferred
instances or occasions
it it is in which it is preferred for a
person to bathe. Some of these are
specific to women, some of them are
specific to men,
some of them are
unisex, both men and women.
And so far we have mentioned two.
The first
is at each
at each
each time a person wishes to have
relations with
his
or her spouse.
And the second
is bathing for al-mustahadah.
Al-mustahadah, as we've mentioned many
times before, is
a woman who
her menstrual cycle has ended, but the
bleeding has continued.
The third instance
bathing
after
a person experiences unconsciousness.
Now,
when a person faints or experiences some
kind of
unconsciousness.
So, basically, anything outside of
sleep,
then
it is the sunnah to bathe upon waking.
[Silence]
You call
the holy man film
[Arabic recitation]
authority of Aisha
and her she says
the messenger of Allah S.A.W
fell unconscious when he was in his
final days.
So, let us set the scene here to
understand what it actually happened.
He was
ill
and he had fallen ill after coming back
from a funeral
in
Al-Baqi
which is the cemetery that is right next
and closest to
the prophet S.A.W
masjid. It's the place where most of
the companions are buried and
when he came back, he was starting to
experience a very bad headache. Now, the
prophet
Alayhi Wasallam
was known to have extreme headaches
constantly, migraines. And these
headaches were severe. They were very
severe. And sometimes he would spend
days on end not be not coming out of his
home from these headaches Alayhi
Wasallam.
So, it wasn't really a cause for alarm
at the time.
And so, he remained ill for roughly 14
days, about 2 weeks. And this would
later develop into the illness that
claimed his life
Alayhi Wasallam.
Now,
as he was
in the final days,
he
was told that everyone is ready to make
salah.
So, he
tried to get up and
he lost consciousness.
And then, when he woke up and this loss
of consciousness was probably very
brief, a matter of moments or minutes.
And then, he would wake up and say, "Did
the people pray yet?"
And they responded, "No, they are
waiting for you."
So, he said, "Bring me a mikhdab." A
mikhdab is a big basin of water.
Right? A basin. Usually, you would wash
clothes in them. When I was a kid,
basins were used the same basin
This basin that we had was
orange. It was very
bright orange.
cannot erase it from my mind no
matter how hard I try. That's the basin
that we took our baths in and that's the
basin that we washed our clothes in.
And so
in my mind I see an orange basin, but of
course it wasn't orange. It was a basin
that would be made out of metal, usually
a thin kind of metal. And so they put
water in this basin for him and he took
it and he bathed with it.
But as he finished bathing and tried to
get up again,
he lost consciousness again.
And then he woke up and said, "Did the
people pray yet?"
And the same thing they repeated, "No,
they're waiting for you, oh messenger of
Allah." And he said, "Bring me a basin
of water." And so they bring him a basin
of water and he would bathe and as he
goes to get up to go and lead salah or
you know, to get dressed to go and lead
salah, he'd lose consciousness again.
And this occurred a number of times
until he finally gave up on being able
to go
and lead salah himself.
And so he sent word to Abu Bakr to lead
salah.
Now,
notice how serious they are taking
salah.
Very seriously.
This is a huge major event.
We can't just have any old person lead
salah, right? No, this is a major event
leading salah. And so they are
waiting for him and he chooses Abu Bakr
to lead salah.
Radiyallahu anhu.
So the point taken here from this
particular narration and this context is
that one of the instances in which it is
preferred for a person to bathe is after
loss of consciousness.
Now,
that is taken from this narration. Do we
know why that is? Most likely to help
wake a person up, to help fully come
back from the unconsciousness that they
were in. But, regardless of what it is
for, we know that it is the Sunnah
because the Prophet
did it. It may have a physical purpose
to it, but being that he did it, if we
do it
in the way that he did it, it is
considered worship in our in our
as as applied to us, it is considered
worship. And the scholars have taken
these things that he uses or that he
does that are otherwise mundane things
and listed them in detail, considering
it an act of worship to emulate the
Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam in
these things. To the point that we have
very close detail as to which side he
would wear his sword on, how he would
wear his armor, how he would sit on his
horse, Sallallahu alayhi wasallam, which
side of the horse he would get on first.
Why do these things matter? Well, these
things are not acts of worship per se in
themselves,
but when a person does it out of love of
the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
and in copying him and emulating him, it
becomes a kind of and a sort of act of
worship to do so.
[Arabic recitation]